what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be talking about um
something i kind of briefly mentioned in
my last video with my brother that you
guys were a little bit upset about um
and i just want to clarify what i meant
by it so in the last video
um i did with my brother we reacted to
kevin samuels video
and in the video um i mentioned i said
something along the lines of i don't
have it like quote for quote but
i said something along the lines of um i
said to my brother only 10
of guys make 100k he said what that's it
and i said yeah like not a lot of people
want to work that hard um a lot of
people took offense to that because they
thought i was discounting um
like firemen and like you know people
that might not make that much money
but um are also hard workers and i'm
definitely not like i have a lot of
respect for like
firemen police officers construction
workers all the you know things you guys
put in the comments
um here's what i actually meant by that
um
there are very there's two type of
people types of people that work hard
um there are people that work hard um
they get a job they work hard at that
job for 20 years make the right decision
save money whatever
cool um
and then there's the other type of
person and that's the type of person
that starts a business right takes risk
and also works hard and this
first type of person very common i meet
people like that all the time but
i say this all the time people want to
be
as wealthy and successful as my dad is
but there are very few people that i
think would actually want it if they
knew what goes into it
um couple things that people don't
realize one my dad worked
probably 80 90 hours a week my entire
life
he missed a lot like he was gone a lot
he went to
india um which is where
my they um half of their software
company is
he would go to india for a month at a
time and you have to think like would
you be cool with being away from your
family that long in the name of success
a lot of people would not pick that
second thing
um a lot of people don't want
the type of risk that goes into
success and this is what i mean
my parents my dad's been successful from
a yearly age she's worked
again a lot of hours my whole life that
puts you ahead of a lot of people
um from a young age because again the
majority of people don't want to do that
there's nothing wrong it doesn't mean
they're lazy
it's just a lot of people don't want to
work 80 90 hours a week
i'm one of them like um i'm definitely
one of those people
so but what comes with that is you have
to incur
a level of risk so that means let's say
you work your ass off you save for 10
years
you put 100 of that money into an
investment
that may or may not pan out so you could
lose everything and my dad almost did he
invested he bought an entire um a huge
plot of land started developing it to
become a neighborhood
um in 2006 2007.
we almost lost like our house our
college fund like everything like i
don't even know how they figured that
out or got out of it
but the majority of people don't want
that type of risk
and it's totally okay to not want that
type of risk i don't if i had a husband
that like
wanted to do that i would support him
100 but
i'm not the type of person that's gonna
risk
my entire life i would never invest a
hundred percent of my money into one
stock that i thought would pan out
and that essentially is business so um
that's what i meant i did not mean that
other people don't work hard
all i meant is people don't typically
want to work
that hard and in in oh my gosh you can't
talk
and incur that level of risk most people
don't want to do it that's okay
doesn't say anything less about them as
a person doesn't mean they're not hard
workers
it's just you know my dad's nuts and
i've known his nuts from a young age
but i hope that clara clarifies things
um i will talk to you guys later